-Right now, guys,
it is time to look at
the stories making headlines
today
and weigh the good with the bad.
It's time for "Pros and Cons."
Here we go.
-♪ Pros and cons
and pros and cons and pros ♪
[ Cheer and applause ]
-Tonight, we'll be taking a look
at the pros and cons
of Biden's first year in office.
He just finished up
his first year as president.
A lot has happened in that time.
So let's look at
the pros and cons of
Biden's first year in office.
Here we go. Pro --
over 200 million Americans
were vaccinated.
Con -- They were all in front of
you in line at CVS.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Let's try the self-checkout."
Pro -- His swearing-in ceremony
was a year ago.
Con -- His swearing-at ceremony
was yesterday.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Stupid s--"
-Peter Douchey.
[ Laughter ]
-It's Doocy.
-Oh, it's not -- It's Doocy?
-Yeah, that's correct.
[ Laughter ]
Pro -- Hospital deaths caused by
omicron are plummeting.
Con -- TV deaths caused by
Peloton are skyrocketing.
[ Laughter ]
This guy died --
What's going on?
-Come on!
-There's got to be
other ways to die.
Pro -- He wants to create
a lasting legacy.
Con -- Or at least make "Biden"
a Wordle answer.
[ Laughter ]
That's cool.
Pro -- He got Tom Hanks
to do a pro-America PSA.
Con -- He got Wilson
the volleyball to run the CDC.
[ Laughter ]
Is that what's happening?
-Yeah. Why would you do that?
-Pro -- He went after
the insurance companies.
Con -- He called the Geico gecko
a stupid son of a --
[ Laughter ]
Why?
-Why would he do that?
-Why?
Pro -- Biden has forgiven
more than $13 billion
in student loan debt.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Con -- Which should cover the
price of about three textbooks.
[ Laughter ]
$2.
-What?
Not even enough for a beer.
-I paid 400 bucks
for each one of these.
Yeah, at least get me a beer,
man.
Pro -- Biden turned 79.
Con -- Which explains why
his approval rating
has fallen and it can't get up.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oy! Clap on.
Pro -- Biden is hoping to
improve his image this year.
Con -- Which explains
his new Cabinet members,
Jonathan, Bobby, Tan,
Antoni and Karamo.
Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And finally, pro --
People wonder if Biden
is getting too old
for another term.
Con -- Even Tom Brady is like,
"Got to know when
to pack it in, bro."
There you have it.
Those are the "Pros and Cons."